plus de 10 voire plus de responsabilités
plus de pouvoir les prochaines élections
marquent un nouveau chapitre dans
l'histoire de la douma la chambre basse
du parlement russe le référendum
constitutionnel de 2020 a
considérablement élargi le pouvoir des
législateurs russe par conséquent ce qui
s'empareront des sièges lors du prochain
scrutin auront un poids politique plus
importants que leurs prédécesseurs la
demande est désormais chargée
d'approuver le premier ministre les
vice-premiers ministres et la plupart
des membres du cabinet dans le passé le
rôle du parlement ici était en grande
partie protocolaire
après tout le président se décharge
d'une partie des pouvoirs très important
si aujourd'hui à ce jour le président
lui-même approuve le président du
gouvernement avec l'accord de la douma
puis en fait sans aucune autorisation du
parlement du pays nomme les ministres
alors la situation change radicalement
maintenant la décision finale relative
au chef du gouvernement est prise par le
parlement lui même comme celles qui
concernent les ministres et le président
dans la version proposée de la
constitution n'a pas le droit de les
rejeter cette grande partie du pouvoir
est dévolu au parlement
c'est un pas de plus vers la
démocratisation de notre société on
avance progressivement sans saccades
mais on va précisément dans cette
direction là
le président peut toujours nommer les
ministres responsables de la sécurité
nationale et de la politique étrangère
sans l'approbation du parlement mais
même avec cette clause les députés
nouvellement élus gagneront plus d'
influence et joueront un rôle plus
important par exemple dans les affaires
économiques intérieures et ce n'est
qu'une part de leurs nouvelles autorités
les amendements de 2020 ont également
renforcé le contrôle parlementaire une
série d'actions en justice que la
demande peut entreprendre pour remanier
différents aspects de la gouvernance du
pays comme les finances par exemple les
députés peuvent convoquer le président
de la banque centrale de russie qui doit
désormais rendre compte à la fois au
président et au parlement avec ce
nouveau pouvoir vient de nouvelles
responsabilités
les futurs députés sont désormais soumis
à un examen plus strictes pour être
autorisé à se présenter ils ne peuvent
avoir de citoyens et étrangère ni de
comptes ou d'actifs dans des banques
situées hors de la russie la pandémie a
poussé les autorités à donner plus de
possibilités pour les votes en ligne
testé pour la première fois lors du
référendum constitutionnel de 2020 c'est
régions russes offriront cette
possibilité à ceux qui ne peuvent ou ne
veulent pas se rendre dans un bureau de
vote de plus le scrutin se déroulera sur
trois jours pour limiter les files
d'attentes le rôle accru du principal
organe législatif du pays ainsi que les
défis organisationnels liés à la
pandémie qui font de cette élection
l'une des plus importantes qui connut la
russie au cours de la dernière décennie